let's get into audience questions I know
Pat has been eagerly waiting to answer
at least a couple of these he I think
have some good stories for us but we're
going to start with Mason Mason wrote in
what one unsolved mystery would you
solve if you could I have two different
answers on this one of them is let's
figure out if Jesus was really born to a
woman who had never had sex died and was
resurrected and is the son of God or a
representative of God on earth because I
feel like so much conflict on our planet
stems from that that if we can get down
to the bottom of it if that's true then
you would see many people convert to
Christianity because they would say hey
you know what we've got proof that Jesus
is God / the son of God and if we can
debunk that then you would see
Christianity presumably dissolved not
completely there would be those who
would say obviously to their last breath
that it was staged the debunking was
staged or whatever but I think that
that's an unsolved mystery that by
virtue of its solving could maybe
improve life on earth for a lot of
people what about that yeah of course
and I mean we don't even know for sure
of course that Jesus lived I mean I
think it's a fair assumption to say that
he did but yeah I mean regardless of
what you think of him and what religion
you follow Jesus Christ is probably the
most influential person in all of human
history whether you're Christian or not
the stories around Jesus are influencing
your life in one way or another for most
people I would say yeah either by
absence or by by their presence in your
life do you have one that you'd like to
solve I'll say one other one I mean
broadly I would love to solve the
question of the origins of the universe
and life within it that's that sort of a
major mystery yeah I know I'm going
beyond whether Paul McCartney was killed
and replaced with a British left-handed
bassist who sings and sounds just like
him at some point forty five fifty years
ago I'm going a little bigger than that
but that's an unsolved that's the
unsolved mystery isn't it right I mean
there's so many different roads you can
go down here I mean one path is
conspiracy theories and other paths is
maybe like paranormal experiences huh
when I was
Edinburgh Scotland I visited a series of
underground tunnels where they used to
bury and trap people who were infected
with diseases tor and there's this
legend of a poltergeist there and people
will come out of these tunnels with
scratches and bruises all over
themselves now some attributed that this
to a ghost others just say well you're
in a dark room of course you can bump
into stuff that can happen sometimes the
simplest explanation is the one that we
should favor and maybe that applies in
that case Occam's razor
um I also would love to solve the
mystery of what happened with building
seven I mean when are we going to get
answers Pat as to what happened with
building seven on that fateful day in
2001 yeah I mean I don't think a debris
falling from two massive skyscrapers
onto it unexpectedly would have any
impact on the structures integrity would
it and that's why we need answers path
because there was thermite paint in
those buildings and anyway I wasn't even
top page news of the day I know yeah I
know hard to believe that it's crazy any
others I don't know I mean there's
certainly sort of uh medical mysteries I
don't mean specifically like guy has a
hundred-pound tumor in his testicles and
it goes away with homie I'm not talking
feel faith-healing or I don't mean that
but I mean broader medical questions
about the future of Medicine but those
aren't really mysteries they're sort of
as yet unknowns I guess you would call
them are there any popular conspiracy
theories that you're at least willing to
entertain like with this assassination
of JFK one I don't think it was you know
orchestrated by Lyndon Johnson or
anything but I think it's entirely
possible that there was more than one
shooter aside from Lee Harvey Oswald
yeah I I don't know I've read a lot
about that and I don't believe that
there was more than one shooter at this
time I'm going to just spend a hell of a
shot you know could have been out you
know that here's the thing with a lot
and we're kind of diverting a little bit
but sometimes with these conspiracy
theories and we're not talking about
conspiracy theories not on solve
mysteries you will have 99 pieces of
evidence that paint a cohesive narrative
and then someone will bring one piece of
evidence or asserted evidence that
doesn't coincide with that the logical
thing would be that's interesting but we
still have these dead
99 pieces of evidence that among
themselves still paint the same picture
conspiracy theorists will sometimes say
well the one piece of evidence alone
makes the other 99 irrelevant and
obviously untrue that's not really
logical that's not really a logical
approach that I find sometimes when when
you get that one thing that doesn't fit
into the overall story or narrative that
we built about something but anyway
we're kind of going in another direction
Jesus and the origins of the universe
maybe would be the two unsolved
mysteries that I would like to solve